uh for those who do not know Sophia and
I did a movie together called Soul Plane
this was actually the first movie um
that you ever did no it was the second
one that I ever did the first one was
Paper Soldiers but this was supposed to
be the movie um that you know launched
my career that put me in a place of real
success Jesse Terrero who I know you
know uh we both Snoop dou in that
sque hugle uh John
Witherspoon um uh know that it was like
I want to say like 18 years ago or
something maybe
longer yeah because it was when I moved
you're right here I moved 20 years ago
to Los Angeles yeah that's that's about
the right time it sounds right 20 years
ago that was like one of my first movies
so so let me ask you a question for me
that movie you know it really was a
pivotable pivotable moment for me in my
career because um although the movie
didn't have box office success because
it got bootleg it had a tremendous
mendous amount of success and allow me
to really kind of take my feet Place him
in a space of stand up build a rapport
with an audience and like grow people
started believing in you no after that
because they were able to see like I
didn't even know who you were until I
saw the movie and I was like oh my God
this guy is amazing and you were so much
more handsome at the time remember yeah
and youer yeah fresher but but you're
doing great no yeah yeah no yeah
absolutely um it weird I think we kind
of I think it took like I thought I
thought you were going like in a space
of compliment and then it said wo it
just went down it was a compliment yeah
well until you said I'm like that was
when I was younger I still feel like
well I'm not lying it's a fact you were
younger 20 years ago yes yeah well I
mean it depends on how you look at me uh
well L I'm 50 now I was like fresh at
that time now I'm like Sophia you look
great yeah I'm serious but I'm 50 you
look great inside I'm 50 inside you're
no actually no inside I feel like I'm
younger but everything what is that what
that
happen no stop it no yeah it's like
everything starting to like you know
it's like you look phenomenal phenomenal
uh my question was going to be what did
that movie do for you what did what the
Soul Plan do for you at that point in
your career it got me money mhm yeah
just pretty much that's it yeah just got
you money did opportunities come because
so I created a lot of you know friends
there was amazing and also I learned a
lot to be on a set doing a movie because
it was like one of my first movies um
then I worked a couple of times with
Tyler
Perry uh so I think yes like you know I
think I then I became part of more
movies that were more for you know black
people Latin people you know that they
were including us so that was a great
time for me that's what I think that
that movie did for me and you you came
from Univision right I remember you were
you were very big in the world of
Univision um how long were you in that
ecosystem well I've been working since I
was like 17 years old but really in
Univision I started working like when I
was
22 and I think I've never stopped you
know really 622 you've been going
non-stop yeah
[Music]
Non-Stop